EASTER.
>> THANK YOU, BRIAN.
YOU DO THE SAME.
>> Brian: ALL RIGHT.
MEANWHILE, MORE THAN 60 MILLION
AMERICANS NOW OUT OF WORK WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
MAKE WHAT HE SAYS IS THE BIGGEST
DECISION OF HIS LIFE.
>> I WANT TO GET IT OPEN AS SOON
AS WE CAN.
WE HAVE TO GET OUR COUNTRY OPEN.
I’M GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION, AND I ONLY HOPE TO GOD
THAT IT IS THE RIGHT DECISION.
BUT I WOULD SAY WITHOUT
QUESTION, IT’S THE BIGGEST
DECISION I’VE EVER HAD TO MAKE.
>> Brian: JOINING ME RIGHT NOW
IS MARK CUBAN, OWNER OF THE
DALLAS MAVERICKS, HAS HUNDREDS
OF HIS OWN BUSINESSES, WANT TO
BE STARS OF "SHARK TANK."
MARK, WHAT SHOULD BE THE
CRITERIA THAT THE PRESIDENT
KEEPS IN MIND WHEN HE MAKES THE
BIGGEST DECISION OF HIS LIFE?
>> I THINK HE NEEDS MORE
INFORMATION.
I THINK YOU CAN JUST USE THE
DEATH RATE AND THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ILL OR SICK OR
ANYTHING.
YOU GOT TO GO OUT AND START
TALKING TO BUSINESSES ABOUT WHAT
THEY SEE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
I WOULD DO A SURVEY, I WOULD
SEND SOMETHING OUT TO COMPANIES
AND SAY, WHEN WE OPEN BACK UP
FULLY, DO YOU ANTICIPATE, A,
HIRING THE SAME NUMBER OF
PEOPLE, B, MORE, C LESS?
I WOULD SEND THE SURVEY TO
EMPLOYEES AND SAY, DO YOU
ANTICIPATE GOING BACK TO THE JOB
HE LEFT, WITH THE JOB YOU ARE
FIRED FROM?
OR DO YOU ANTICIPATE GOING TO A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT JOB?
OR DO YOU ANTICIPATE NOT GOING
AFTER A JOB AT ALL?
DON’T WANT TO WORK?
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE INFORMATION
TO GIVE SOME INDICATION OF WHAT
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE LIKE
AFTER THIS RESET.
>> Brian: WHAT ABOUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THESE BUSINESS
OWNERS?
WHEN I WALK INTO A BUILDING,
SHOULD THEY BE TAKING MY
TEMPERATURE OF MY FOREHEAD?
SHOULD I TAKE THE ABBOTT TEST TO
SEE IF I HAVE THE VIRUS?
WHEN I GO TO LUNCH, DO I TAKE
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE TESTS?
WHAT SHOULD PEOPLE BE PREPARED
TO DO?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE BUSINESSES
SHOULD BE PREPARED TO INTRODUCE
WHATEVER SCIENCE TELLS US WE
NEED TO INTRODUCE.
WHATEVER DR. FAUCI AND COMPANY
TELLS US IS NECESSARY, THAT’S
WHAT WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO
DO.
BUT ALONG THOSE LINES, WHEN
THERE’S UNCERTAINTY, WE REALLY
GOING TO HAVE TO ADJUST OUR
BUSINESSES.
RESTAURANTS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
REALIGN THE TABLES.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT, THE
AMERICAN AIRLINES CENTER, HOW WE
ARE GOING TO FIT PEOPLE.
THERE’S JUST SO MANY DIFFERENT
VARIABLES WE HAVE TO CONSIDER,
WERE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO BE
AGILE.
>> Brian: LET’S TALK SPORTS
FOR A SECOND.
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" SAID A
QUOTE TODAY I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU AND GET YOUR THOUGHTS.
ON ONE SPORTS IS GOING TO START
AGAIN.
’S ARE GOING TO COME BACK SOON?
THE QUOTE: "WE WILL NOT HAVE
SPORTING EVENTS WITH FANS UNTIL
WE HAVE A VACCINE," ACCORDING TO
SOMEONE WHO WROTE THE
DISSERTATION ON THE NFL.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> AGAIN, I DON’T WANT TO
PRETEND I’M A SCIENTIST APPEAR
ON THE WRONG PERSON TO ASK HIM
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE, BUT THERE ARE SCIENTISTS
WE TRUST, AND WHATEVER THEY TELL
US, THAT’S WHAT NBA IS GOING TO
DO.
AS AN EMPLOYER, UNTIL I HAVE
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY MY EMPLOYEES
ARE GOING TO BE HEALTHY GOING TO
WORK, NOT GOING TO ASK THEM TO
DO SO.
YOU KNOW, IF I HAD TO GUESS, I
DO THINK WE WILL PLAY GAMES
WITHOUT FANS, INITIALLY, AND
THEN, AS WE GO MORE CONFIDENT
WHEN BACK TO WORK AND GOING INTO
CROWDS, THEN WE WILL START TO
EXPLORE WHETHER TO BRING FANS
INTO THE ARENA AND STADIUM.
>> Brian: IT WILL BE VERY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE AFTER 9/11,
WE CHANGED THE WAY WE DID THINGS
THROUGH THE TURNSTILES,
DISTANCING GOING THROUGH THE
TURNSTILES.
WE COULD HAVE EVERY THIRD SEAT
BEING SOLD.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT COULD
HAPPEN, BUT I IMAGINE A GUY LIKE
YOU WILL BE BROUGHT IN ON THAT
THOUGHT PROCESS, BECAUSE THERE
IS THE SCIENCE, AND THERE’S THE
PRACTICAL, I OWN A SPORTS TEAM
AND I KNOW THIS IS POSSIBLE,
RIGHT, MARK?
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION, YOU’RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TALK TO YOUR
CUSTOMERS AND BUILD UP THAT
CONFIDENCE.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
YOU MENTIONED 9/11.
IF I PART OF THE PROGRAM WHERE
GIVING MONEY TO AIRLINES, ONE OF
THE THINGS THE GOVERNMENT MAY
CONSIDER DOING IS PREBUYING
SEATS, BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT
SPENDS A LOT OF MONEY ON
COMMERCIAL TRAVEL.
SO I NOT PARTNER WITH THE
AIRLINES AS PART OF THIS DEAL
AND HAVE FEDERAL EMPLOYEES DO
SOME OF THE TESTING ON FLYING ON
AIRLINES?
BECAUSE IF WE CAN BUILD
CONFIDENCE THAT HE CAN TRAVEL
IN A PLANE COMFORTABLY AND
WITHOUT RISK, THAT’S GOING TO
BUILD THE CONFIDENCE THE PEOPLE
CAN GO INTO CONFINED PLACES OR
WHERE THERE’S A LOT OF PEOPLE,
BUT THAT HAS TO BE PART OF THE
PROGRAM, THINGS WE LOOK FOR,
BECAUSE AGAIN, IT COMES DOWN TO
SCIENCE AND BUILDING CONFIDENCE.
>> Brian: SO MARKET, THE
PRESIDENT ON TUESDAY IS GOING TO
NAME THIS COUNCIL ABOUT BRINGING
AMERICA BACK ECONOMICALLY AND
PUTTING US BACK TO WORK.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ON THAT
COUNSEL OR BE CONSIDERED?
>> ANYWAY I CAN SERVE MY
COUNTRY, I’M ALL IN.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO IF THEY ASK.
>> Brian: THAT’LL BE GREAT.
SOMETIMES THE PRESIDENT WATCHES.
I KNOW HE’S NOT ALLOWED TO DO
MUCH, BECAUSE WE ARE ALL
SHELTERING IN PLACE.
MAYBE HE HEARD THAT IT WILL
CALL.
LASTLY --
>> I HOPE SO.
>> Brian: I HOPE SO COME ALSO
SO.
NO MATTER WHAT SHOW YOU ARE ON,
RADIO, TV, YOU PUT YOUR COUNTRY
FIRST, AND I HAVE NO IDEA HOW
YOU STAY POLITICAL, AND PEOPLE
LOOK AT YOUR TRACK RECORD AND
RESUME AND SUCCESS, AND AFTER
CALL YOUR NUMBER.
LASTLY, LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED SO FAR WITH A
$2.2 TRILLION AND HOW IT AFFECTS
SMALL BUSINESSES.
$340 BILLION.
DO YOU THINK IT IS WORKING?
>> I THINK THE PROGRAM IS A GOOD
PROGRAM.
I THINK THE EXECUTION HAS
SUFFERED SOME.
I THINK THE BANKS ARE ACTING TOO
MUCH LIKE BANKS.
THEY ARE GOING TO NEED TO BE
FORCED TO SAY, JUST TO GIVE THE
LOANS FIRST, AND WE WILL DEAL
WITH FRAUD AND PROBLEMS AFTER
THE FACT.
BECAUSE IT’S COSTING US MORE IN
LOST JOBS AND COMPANIES GOING
OUT OF BUSINESS BY HOLDING
THINGS UP AND SLOWING DOWN THE
LOANS THAT IT COST US AND
FRAUD.
HOPEFULLY THINGS WILL SPEED UP
AND WE WILL LOOK BACK AND SAY IT
WAS A SLOW WEEK TO START THINGS
OFF, BUT RIGHT NOW, IT’S A
CHALLENGE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES,
AND A LOT OF MY COMPANIES ARE
REALLY CONCERNED.
>> Brian: RIGHT, AND THEY
CAN’T TELL YOU TO RETAIN LABOR,
AND THEN TELL YOU FIND YOUR
MONEY ELSEWHERE TO PAY YOUR
RENT, TAKE CARE OF YOUR LEASE
COME AND KEEP YOUR LIGHTS ON AND
MAINTAIN YOUR EQUIPMENT.
>> IT’S NOT EVEN JUST ABOUT
THAT.
PARTICULARLY FOR COMPANIES WITH
INVESTORS, THERE ARE THINGS
CALLED AFFILIATE RULES WHICH THE
BANKS ARE SAYING, IF YOU HAVE
THIS INVESTOR OR A COMPANY THAT
YOU ARE CONNECTED WITH, UNLESS
YOU’RE A RESTAURANT FRANCHISEE,
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO GET THESE
LOANS, AND THERE’S SO MUCH
CONFLICTING INFORMATION ON THAT
AFFILIATES PROGRAM THAT
COMPANIES THAT HAVE TAKEN
INVESTORS, MORE THAN 50% HAVE
TAKEN INVESTMENT AT SOME LEVEL,
ARE REALLY FREAKING OUT.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
LET’S GO DOWN AND TALK TO PEOPLE
AND THEN GET THE ANSWERS.